diese kinder benötigen dringend hilfe
nach der explosion in beirut und viele
kliniken zerstört und überlastet
besonders betroffen sind rund 120 junge
krebspatienten ihre therapien wurden
ausgesetzt
medikamente sind knapp eines der kinder
ist anthony bus thani der 13 jährige
leitet an schwere leukämie während der
explosion bekam der schüler gerade seine
chemotherapie
dabei krachte eine fensterscheibe direkt
auf sein bett es ist furchtbar
bei jedem kleinsten geräusch habe ich
angst ich kann nicht schlafen
die explosion hat mein leben zerstört
durch die chemotherapie hat anthony
orale mukositis bekommen seine
mundschleimhaut ist extrem entzündet
wenn er spricht tut es weh um sich
abzulenken hat der 13 eg eine kleine
schildkröte als haustier aber das ist
noch nicht genug
seine eltern können sich die medikamente
die bis zu mehrere tausend euro kosten
nicht mehr leisten betreut werden die
kinder von der hilfsorganisation chance
die präsidentinnen dr hohler ferrari
schlägt alarm
denn die situation könnte wie viele
kinder dramatischer nicht sein label to
continue the chicks on time
wir wissen nicht ob diese kinder ihre
behandlung rechtzeitig bekommen oder ob
die versorgung ausreicht die kinder
mussten ihre krankenbetten verlassen
weil die kliniken zerstört wurden und in
den krankenhäusern ist alles voll mit
verletzten
wir versuchen alles diesen kindern zu
helfen aber wir wissen nicht wie sich
die medizinische lage in den nächsten
wochen und monaten entwickeln wird
die explosion hat die behandlungschancen
deutlich verschlechtert das lager für
die medikamente wurde teilweise zerstört
noch ist unklar wie viele reserven
vorhanden sind